and this morning we have some sad news
about actress Anne Hayes she is in a
coma after a car crash a week ago and
her family said last night she is not
expected to survive haish was
hospitalized after driving her car into
a house in Los Angeles Carter Evan joins
us now with more on the story Carter
good morning to you this is in fact very
sad news when the story first happened
we saw friends and family members going
into the hospital saying she's going to
be all right that is clearly very much
changed what are they saying now
certainly things have changed good
morning Gail the statement they released
is really heartbreaking they speak of
Anne Heche in the past tense saying she
had a huge heart and touched everyone
with her generous spirit
this is Anne Heche in March attending
the Director's Guild award in Beverly
Hills five months later her car was seen
speeding down a street on LA's west side
where she crashed into a home narrowly
missing a woman Inside So recovering and
trying to figure out up from down haish
never regained Consciousness after being
pulled from the fiery wreckage suffering
Burns and what doctors described as a
significant pulmonary injury forcing her
to breathe with a ventilator haitious
injuries will most likely prove to be
fatal in a statement her family says it
has long been her choice to donate her
organs and she's being kept on life
support to determine if any are viable
hey I'm here with somebody you remember
him he came in with me in her movie
career haitious star Shone most brightly
in the 90s starting in hit movies like
Six Days Seven Nights Donnie Brasco and
Wag the Dog
[Applause]
it was also in the 90s that we followed
her very public relationship with Ellen
DeGeneres after their breakup in 2000
she married camera operator Coleman
lafoon after their divorce she entered a
decade-long relationship with actor
James Tupper I mean just look around
people are celebrating each other
personal troubles in her 2001 Memoir
call me crazy she wrote of her lifelong
struggles with mental health and a
childhood of abuse by her father
and Hayes turned 53 in May she continued
to have an active film and TV career and
according to IMDb she has six projects
either completed or in post-production
right now and another that was about to
start Tony
oh boy Carter as Gail said very sad news
there thank you very much for that
report